president Trump is using his executive
authority to make progress on fulfilling
two of his signature campaign promises
on Friday the president announced he
will not certify Iran to be in
compliance with the landmark nuclear
deal that the Obama administration
negotiated with Tehran and five other
nations mr. Trump stopped short of
tearing up the deal as he repeatedly
promised during the campaign it comes
one day after he ended payments that
keep millions of Americans insured under
Obama care in a tweet late last night
the president said those payments to
insurance companies are over and urged
congressional Democrats to come to the
table Erol Barnett's following all this
he's at the White House Erol good
morning good morning yes president Trump
is taking an axe to two pillars of
policy from the Obama administration
ending the week both moving away from
the Iran nuclear deal and rolling back
key subsidies for Obamacare President
Trump saying he is simply following
through on one promise after another we
cannot and will not make this
certification while not officially
breaking away from the Iran nuclear deal
President Trump did highlight the option
telling Congress to address his concerns
with the country's behavior and reimpose
sanctions if Iran does not comply we
will deny the regime all paths to a
nuclear weapon but Iran and the other
five countries signatory to the deal are
staying on track the UK France and
Germany issued a joint statement saying
they stand committed to the plans full
implementation the president's own
national security team confirms the deal
is working and I do believe the
agreement to date has delayed the
development of a nuclear capability by
Iran for that reason Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff Joseph Dunford
and Secretary of Defense Jim mattis
signed off on this current action which
keeps the u.s. involved for now I can
sign up myself I don't need anybody
president Trump is also intent in taking
his own action against Obamacare signing
an executive order which slashes seven
billion dollars in annual payments to
insurers funds design
to bring down costs on the individual
market that money is going to insurance
companies to lift up their stock price
if you have a pre-existing medical
condition you better be very very rich
beyond the unified opposition from
Democrats who call the order sabotage
Nevada's Republican Governor Brian
Sandoval warned of the human cost it's
gonna hurt people with mental health
issues that's gonna hurt veterans it's
going to hurt everybody the nonpartisan
Congressional Budget Office warns
eliminating subsidies could prompt
insurers to hike rates 20% next year
that's if they don't leave the exchange
at the Values Voter Summit President
Trump said congressional inaction forced
his hand we're taking a little different
route than we had hope because getting
Congress they forgot what their pledges
were now as far as the future of us
participation in the Iran deal CBS News
has learned that the White House intends
to keep diplomatic channels with Tehran
open through the Joint Commission which
oversees compliance but president Trump
has still yet to appoint his official
envoy to that Commission Anthony
Errol Barnett at the White House thanks
Harold